the smashing pumpkins and jane's
addiction will be going out on the
spirits on fire tour this october and
november and i'll take that in for a
minute these two great bands with these
two great front men it's orgasmic it'll
be beautiful i could just we have a long
long crazy history where the bands kind
of intersected and
um like the quick start of our story is
um the pumpkins open for jane's in 1988
the week nothing shocking was coming out
i believe
right around thanksgiving and we didn't
know each other then but that's the
first time we all kind of met and we
literally have had this crazy history
back and forth through all these years
so it's it's beautiful describe the
excitement of a neutral are we excited
about this tour and i say this to me as
a
non-musician
the idea of starting a tour
figuring out the set list to me it all
seems romantic even when i see videos of
guys doing sound checks like to you guys
it might be a nuisance but to me it
seems so exciting you walk into the
venue
you're doing the sound check uh the
people you hang with backstage i i could
see it as being fabulous
but i bet it sucks sometimes i bet it's
just horrible because people are
constantly grabbing at you there's
constant fighting there's constant
business things to discuss which is it
is it exciting or is it kind of scary i
will tell you this
so as i say as i've gotten older and
wiser
my health has improved
immensely just by being here
and seeing all the the crew and the
musicians
now i look at it like
it's in a way it's my lifeline i i
become almost like
the thought i i feel like i'm eternal as
long as there's people that need joy in
their life
and i see their faces when i'm singing
i'm like wow i'm giving these guys joy
you know i'm turning them on i'm turning
them on
i i tell you i age back back 10 years
just yesterday what i would say is
we're about to go on tour with one of
the
greatest bands ever on god's green's
earth
let me tell you what the smashing
pumpkins are
by nature a competitive lot
and
to share a stage each night with jane's
addiction
they'll kick our ass if we're not
careful but the beauty the beautiful
thing is is there's there's so much
family love between the two camps
so it's it's it's like brothers beating
their chest you know i mean i really i
really want jane's at their best and and
i want us at our best and yeah that's
the way we're going to show our our love
for each other to the audience
we will give our supreme effort each
night